[Music]
this is a very special edition of
chicken 25 years ago the Maastricht
Treaty went into effect founding the
European Union to commemorate that
occasion I'm going to be hopping back
and forth between Germany and France
while spending time in Freiburg and
Strasbourg I hope to discover a few
things about the two nations India sink
recedes and similarities
[Music]
my journey begins in Freiburg in Germany
Southwest this region has been greatly
influenced by the French it was even
under French rule for a time in the 17th
century some king louis xiv had a
fortress built on this hill called the
Schlossberg there's not much left of the
fortification today but it's worth
climbing up to the site to get an
overview of the city one of the many
advantages of the European Union is that
its inner borders have long ago seized
to constitute an obstacle for travelers
and citizens and all the more excited to
find out what awaits me on my border
hopping route how much of France will I
find in Freiburg and how much of Germany
over in Strasburg
[Music]
one absolute must see in Freiburg is the
famous Minster a gothic masterpiece this
Cathedral was built between the 13th and
16th centuries and here's a fun fact
when seeking other employment architects
and laborers had to prove they'd worked
on the cathedral a clever way was
devised to do that they just had to say
where to find the devil hiding on the
cathedrals main entrance
[Music]
and if you'd like to hobnob with the
local crowd you should pop by the market
on the Cathedral Square
here you'll find stands selling products
from all around the region and that
includes France homage Northwest of
Freiburg still in Germany you'll find
the kaiser stool a low mountain range of
volcanic origin the region is one of the
warmest in Germany and best known for
its wine perfect excuse for a tasting
but it's not just your taste buds that
are in for a treat
along the Upper Rhine you'll also find
some amazing architecture like at the
avril vineyards which carry on
century-old traditions in modern
facilities
[Music]
thus must my special about wine from the
Kaiser store can you tell it's from here
by the smell of the Kaiser school easy
on the Kaiser stool is an inactive
volcano that's why we have very
interesting soil formations we have
plenty of this but underneath that
there's very dark decomposed volcanic
soil it's really crucial for us our best
wines grow well in that dark soil and we
think you can taste it in our wine the
minerality which is typical of Kaiser
stew a burgundy you'll be hard-pressed
to find a wine like that anywhere else
in Germany sounds great I'm picking up
honey yes a trace of honey exactly
Lesley what else does the expert smell
how's it for me well I can detect a note
of honeydew melon it does have a rather
fruity taste there are some slight
traces of vanilla from the wooden barrel
and when you take a sip you get it
tastes completely different than it
smells exactly the flavor of local fruit
slowly reveals itself the taste of ripe
apples ripe pears combined with a really
nice minerality and that flavor stays in
your mouth for a very long time it was
you must try this it's delicious
[Music]
by now I've crossed the border from
Germany to France I'm in Strasbourg
Alsace is regional capital has a long
history the Celts were here as well as
the Romans the Huns and the Franconian
zhh in the Middle Ages Strasburg was
part of the Holy Roman Empire of German
nations and Strasberg's Cathedral does
bear a striking resemblance to the one
in Freiburg no wonder they were built
around the same time where are you from
Atlanta Georgia and the United States
beautiful this is completely different
what do you what do you like about it I
love the age the history is so charming
beautiful what's your impression of the
city it's the first time I come here I
feel amazingly peace of church we love
Europe we always try to get over here
from Argentina when we have time
frequency operator
another tourist hotspot is the pity
Falls quarter with its half-timbered
houses Strasberg's Old Town has been
declared a world cultural heritage site
by UNESCO that's also the case with the
so-called new town where you'll find
monuments from the times of the German
Empire in the 19th century
hello and welcome to your Parliament the
European Parliament the city of
Strasbourg is the official seat of the
European Parliament
since we are right here below this ray
of light there's always this wow factor
when you step inside even those of us
who've worked here for years never get
over it where do the interpreter send
the interpreters sit down there in those
booths we currently have 24 official
languages visitors have a right to
understand what members of parliament
are saying here in the plenary Hall
there's room for 748 m EPS and 650
visitors
we end our tour on the roof overlooking
France and Germany over there you can
see the black forest and there are the
Vosges mountains though they're harder
to see and there's the Cathedral
[Music]
[Music]
my franco-german war between Freiburg
and Strasburg ends right on the border
in this case the Rhine River
[Music]
it's a symbolic place a bridge
connecting two countries that were more
than once at war this is the passage led
to Heath the bridge of the two banks a
bridge crossing a border river there may
not be a better symbol for European
unity a thing I've learned a lot about
on my trip from Germany to France and
back one could almost forget that the
European Union as we know it today has
only been around for 25 years happy
birthday and keep up the good work
you